like ready to think he's tinkling to the
next challenge is funny nights queen of
comedy and a car ready yeah bring up
dick accompany just call me a [ __ ] yeah
we better get used to it right i kitchen
what are you doing I'm cutting up an
onion a red onion no what are you making
your donor Oh Thai green curry whose
recipe was stolen from it's a my wife
she's a Thai bride you'd be on the
internet again everything get pace
yourself ordering things what she's no
God no I wasn't yeah Allen's doing a
Thai green chicken curry so obviously
the same in here I've got the ginger the
chilies yeah the coriander root a little
bit of garlic and lemongrass blitz that
up to a paste
okay now pop the cumin in fennel seed
and sesame seed then I'm gonna pop the
red onion and the garlic in and the
chili your dad was a very successful
book manager yeah how does he feel what
you told him you again what direction
well I never told him did I mean when
your campers me there's no bit we go sit
down everyone I've got a seeker Alan's
cutting off the chicken breasts and I've
got in my aubergine see really nice
white aubergine chicken thigh free range
of course and sweat that off what I like
about this is yes because I put the red
onion in you can't really tell if the
chickens down or not what's a little
spice you know will it be edible or
someone died I'm also putting in the
juice of the lime and then I'm just
going to add soy sauce now listen the
Friday night project since you've been
on the show Justin Lee Collins okay yeah
has almost doubled in size
oh feeder I mean what's going on mate
great now because I look smelt next I
know you do and I know right now it's
like a big grizzly bear but we like our
food and you eat in bed together yeah
yeah problems get everywhere is that
burnt oh look it's a little bit burnt if
you not smell that that was a [ __ ]
burn bell now
now we'll add the coconut cream a secret
ingredient palm sugar slice the basil
and the kind of we wanted to really
bleed and go really nice and green then
finally a tablespoon of fish sauce why
don't your screen and why does mine look
like you did cuz I'm a chef or you're a
cook I haven't seen you taste it yet
well smelling it was all right now nice
in that it's nothing nice nice you won't
admit any guy it's actually quite nice I
love the way you put the rice in the
play I would already that's why I do
they look just look at yours look at
mine huh I think you'll be pleasantly
surprised good luck yes yeah your leader